so we are the largest lead generator of
prospective franchisee leads in the
country so if you're a guy in
dayton ohio and you've just had enough
your boss is just a lunatic and you feel
like you're not appreciated
uh and you're not making enough money
you google best franchise for under 200
000 or whatever you google
odds are you'll come to either our site
franchise help or one of the sites where
the back end tech behind
and
so that's step one next part on the
value chain is like working those leads
and we developed a a communication tool
called fran funnel which helps people
work that franchise lead
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking to rob huntington
the ceo of metro collective before
matric rob was a consultant with the
boston consulting group for multiple
fortune 500 companies he also received
the bcg social impact fellowship and
served in nicaragua he led a turnaround
of the huntington learning centers as
the svp of development and operations
prior to that he was an hlc franchisee
additionally he has been a franchise
broker with the franchise consulting
company and managed a 15 million dollar
pnl for davita a fortune 200 company
let's talk about franchising
rob huntington welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm doing well thank
you nice to be here thank you thank you
very very much for being here where are
you calling from right now
uh northern new jersey ridgewood new
jersey
ridgewood new jersey well it's great to
have you here rob and we're going to be
talking about franchising and it's
something that we i don't hear often you
know in general and i'm excited to dive
deep into what this means in this next
20 minutes and not just about what it
means but what it meant for your career
and also what it means you know for
young entrepreneurs that are thinking
about their career trajectory and what
that might mean for them so so rob tell
me a little bit about your own career
path and the different you know changes
you've made and and how you've sort of
converged on this idea of franchising
and also you know on a more you know on
a more concrete and theoretical level
so
the
maybe going through the history is the
easiest way to answer that uh wonderful
right out of college i um well i delayed
the inevitable and went to ecuador
taught english to make money and did a
bunch of volunteer work
and then became a teacher in an in an
inner city school um history teacher i
love teaching
and then i started working for my family
business my family started a tutoring
franchisor with about 150 million
dollars of brand revenue and
started on the ground floor worked my
way up to managing our biggest store
then bought a franchise myself that had
been run into the ground turned it
around sold it went to kellogg for
business school
after that went to bcg did the
management consulting gig where you make
powerpoint slides and excel models for
you know 18 hours a day six or seven
days a week
and um and from there went back to my
family business um
and really started to fall in love with
franchising there it's it's a great
model and
with a franchise you buy a system like a
way of doing business
and
their franchise their their bias is
outstanding like it makes a really
profound difference in kids lives and it
does it through process like really
being systematic about how you approach
education
so when i was back there um we were
struggling uh the the business was
closing 30 units a year and only opening
one or two i led the turnaround of that
and um then it turns out that family
businesses are kind of tricky places to
work and didn't see the eye to eye with
my folks i left took a job managing a 50
million dollar p l for a fortune 200
company
hated working for the man went back to
franchising became a framework broker
and then met my now partners and through
a series of deals we we continued to
deepen our partnership till
eventually i am uh now ceo of metric
collective which is a vertically
integrated franchise tech company
what is that what does that even mean a
franchise tech company
we've been debating that so that's our
tagline like it's a mouthful so um
is it tough to say and i don't know that
that's how it's always going to be said
we're six months into this deal but it
is legit like we do have all of those
elements so vertically integrated means
we play across the whole value chain of
franchising so we are the largest lead
generator of prospective franchisee
leads in the country so if you're a guy
in
dayton ohio and you've just had enough
your boss is just a lunatic and you feel
like you're not appreciated
and you're not making enough money you
google best franchise for under 200 000
or whatever you google
odds are you'll come to either our site
franchise help or one of the sites where
the backend tech behind
and
so that's step one next part on the
value chain is like working those leads
and we developed a communication tool
called fran funnel which helps people
work that franchise lead it was recently
rated the number one tech tool in
franchising ahead of companies like
salesforce and hubspot which i'm not
sure the the dimensions that we are
being ranked on it's certainly not
revenue um but uh but people love us
like it's a super useful tool and i used
it myself when i was a franchise broker
so
maybe what would be helpful you know for
somebody who doesn't really understand
franchising that well tell me a little
bit about what it was like you know
without technology and then what what
are the different pain points within the
franchising journey that you're able to
to ameliorate or augment through metro
collective so through metric collective
we we help franchise sales folks do
better with our tech we get them leads
we get them huge quantities of leads
that they then work and they can work
them using our tech in a systematic way
when you're buying internet leads like
there's a lot of garbage in there that
you have to sift through to find the
people who are legit
um and then the next step we can do is
be a fully outsourced franchise company
uh sales company so someone can say like
i'm great at teaching jiu jitsu or
baking pizza i have no idea how to sell
franchises we said great we'll be here
outsource franchise sales company
so what does that actually mean to sell
franchises so maybe i need you to take
me back one step backwards and talk to
me more about the pain point that you're
coming to solve
so to sell a franchise selling franchise
is a hard thing to do if you don't know
how to do it like anything once you know
how to do it it's not all that hard
um
so what does that even mean tangibly to
solve friendship so say you're you've
got a pizza shop and you make great
pizza and you want to expand
you
franchising's a way in which you can
expand it's a beautiful way in which you
can expand because you're using other
people's money to expand who have skin
in the game so rather than build like
having to do a capital raise and build
out corporate stores and build out the
whole like military-s hierarchy that
would be needed for a you know like a
bunch of stores
you say to someone hey you've got a high
net worth or depending on the model some
models require high net worth some don't
you want to take down you know southern
new york for pizza stores so you can buy
that territory from us we'll give you
the manual on how to bake this pizza
like where we source the dough from like
the specific techniques we do
all that stuff how we think about
customer service
and that person then gets the rights to
open the franchise in
southern new york
that sale is a complicated sale you have
to go through a whole bunch of legal
regulation there's a whole bunch of
documents that need to be prepared
and if you're good at making pizza and
selling pizza you're not necessarily
going to be good at selling franchises
you're now selling a you know million
dollar thing as opposed to a 20 thing
so we can help people do that
i see so so obviously there's a huge
difference between selling a million
dollar business idea rather than a 20
pizza box but
what what what are the differences
tangibly in the selling point and what
are the different preparations that one
needs to make that you are helping them
through metro collective
so
we help a franchise business think about
whether they're ready for franchising
like
it's hard it it's not the right answer
for everyone
it's a beautiful model in a number of
ways like
tim harford that the economist from
britain had had
the idea that the llc is maybe one of
the best inventions of humankind up
there with like
sanitation and the wheel and things like
that franchising's not like in that
league but i think it's a beautiful
invention
in a similar way like the llc a
beautiful invention because it enables
business like it it breaks liability
away and it means that people can do all
the stuff that your guests do um without
fear of like going to debtors prison if
it doesn't work out
um franchising is a beautiful way to put
skin in the game and create wealth for a
whole bunch a whole bunch of people so
first person is the actual franchisee
when you're that guy in dayton ohio and
you're miserable and you're like you
know what i want to
take ownership of my life i want to
build wealth i want to build something i
can pass on to my kids
franchising can be that and you have to
do it well like you can't pick a crappy
model but once you pick a good model and
it takes some thought and effort to pick
a good model but once you pick a good
model then you follow the system and as
long as you're well capitalized and you
actually follow the system sometimes
people buy a franchise and then don't
follow the system and that ends up being
a disaster because you bought the thing
to follow the system not like reinvent
it
um you can do really well like you can
build up a serious income stream you can
get to the place where you have a team
of people working for you and you can
either be absentee or you can just keep
driving and building a big bigger and
bigger empire
um and then you're building enterprise
value so you can sell it unlike a job at
the end of the day
so great for franchisees great for
franchisors so franchisors private
equity is just starting to realize this
in a really big way um
franchisors partner with that franchisee
who then grows the business throughout
the country and they're using their
equity and their debt to build up your
brand
the margins get crazy so once you're a
franchisor at scale your margin can be
like 60 like of the order of magnitude
of like visa and mastercard like
eye-ordering margins as a franchisor
which is why you have deals like just
recently kkr bought neighborly a big
franchise aggregator
for a crazy number and just i don't know
like 10 12 years ago neighborly was a 50
million dollar company trading hands and
lower middle market private equity now
it's getting bought by kkr and a large
part of that is because of just the
giant origins and how it how franchising
puts skin in the game of the local owner
uh right so great for franchisees great
for franchisors and also great for
investors because when you invest in
something like that you get pretty
phenomenal returns
right and so what have you learned from
working with people that are new to the
franchising world that are making this
transition and they're reconfiguring
their train of thought they're
reconfiguring the way they think about
business and about what their potential
business could be well what are some of
the you know behaviors that you're
seeing that you know may not be so
trivial to someone who's not aware of
this whole transition
fear is the biggest one it's terrifying
for people they're like you know i've
been on a career path my whole life i am
a software engineer in
dayton ohio making a good income
you're telling me i should like and i
have a net worth of a million bucks
you're telling me i should like borrow
against that and put 300 000 into this
franchise that might then need like
another hundred thousand like it's a
serious commitment um
and do you want to get i don't know that
i got those numbers right right off the
top of my head like you don't want to
sell someone that is beyond their means
uh 100
so like a lot of the franchisees we deal
with will be a guy who owns 30 orange
theories and now is looking for the next
concept and has a big business with a
serious evidence
um right
so but for someone who's new to it fear
is the big one and then understanding
risk i think a lot of people misprice
risk in franchising so they look at it
like
franchising is crazy risky and
it can be but if you're thoughtful if
you have a sufficient capital buffer if
you believe in your own skills and
talents like don't do franchising if
you're incompetent but if you're
competent
then
um you've got the capital you've got the
confidence and then make sure you pick a
good model and a good model is defined
as one that
you can make good money and you can
figure out what money you can make when
you call around other franchisees
there's a thing called an item 19 in
franchise disclosure documents that
tells you for the good franchises what
the p l looks like
and then do the thoughtful due diligence
around like
is this a dying industry or is this a
growing industry if it's a growing
industry and there's a white space in
your market and it seems like something
that would be in your wheelhouse like
you don't want to buy a franchise that
requires sales if you're terrible at
sales you don't want to buy a franchise
that is
heavy on ops and supply chain if you're
terrible in detail but once you control
for all that stuff you can de-risk it i
think de-risk it below the level of a
corporate job so you go and you
juxtapose all that with a corporate job
where like you could have a nightmare
boss you could have colleagues who are
out to get you you could just hate the
company you could get acquired and laid
off and people ignore all those risks
and look at the corporate job kind of as
the safe path whereas a franchise
if you believe in yourself is probably
equally safe i mean the risk profiles
are slightly different but i think
people that fear is the big thing and
then talking through like what the real
risk actually is is a lot of what the
buying decision is for someone who's new
to franchising
right i think that's a really
interesting concept and that when you
know the comparison to the risks that
you might have looking at the safe bet
when you're considering that well there
is actually ways to franchise that may
not be as risky as somebody might think
and you one may even make the case that
franchising could potentially be less
risky than than going for the safe bet
and i think that's a really interesting
comparison so what are some questions
that that you think
you know perhaps a young entrepreneur
would
be able to ask themselves
at some point in their career to know
whether they're ready you know on a
personal level to transition to either
selling a franchise or or buying one
selling a franchise is kind of a
corporate job you can make tons of money
selling franchises once you get good at
it and
um
become credible and know you know who to
sell to and how to do it um to buy a
franchise
it's kind of more of a mid-career thing
like you you typically need some some
capital base
there are lower cost franchises so my
partners and i are have just um
partnered with a franchisor that you can
get in for
a very low dollar amount we actually
offer financing to people who want to
come to that franchise so it can be a
really interesting thing to get into
when um
when you're young if you find one of the
cheaper franchises
uh right you have to find a cheap one
and the cheap ones will require a lot of
shoe leather like a lot of hustle to get
it going like this one in particular
right state sales for like
middle upper income and below so like
not sotheby's and christie's but you
know like
grandma passed away and you need to sell
her stuff
and you can build a really big business
with something like that but it's going
to have a whole different profile than
the guy who's like i want to buy 30 taco
bells
sure
that makes a lot of sense all right so
take me back a little bit to your your
story again and and i really want to
hear about you know your upbringing
before you discover franchising before
you know this becomes a big part of your
life what what you know what really
guides you what is sort of you know your
where does your curiosity take you what
fascinates you
that's a big question um yeah
what fascinates me uh well i aspire to
be a jedi knight one day um
so
i think that the idea um of
enlightenment is pretty cool so okay
aside from achieving
big business success which feels fun and
like a competition i played tons of
sports all growing up so i'd like being
on a team
whether like leading the team or just
being a part of a team i love being part
of an awesome team that works hard and
has camaraderie and all that stuff
um
so
that's a motivator like winning but
enlightenment like i don't know i feel
like that's the right goal to be
shooting for and um the jedi knight
thing flows from like
uh
taoism and i studied tai chi for a while
um so i'd like to figure out if she is
actually real and if i could levitate or
like you know move things um using
energy i haven't yet but i'm cautiously
optimistic
i love it and if you look today where
you gather your sources of inspiration
whether it's personally professionally
big small
you know where where does inspiration
come to you from
i read a bunch um
one of the
a specific thing i came across recently
that was inspiring was um
the virtuosity of coach popovich of the
san antonio's first
so
there there is a plot that looked at
expected wins like using all the stats
of team talent juxtaposed against the
other team's talent and like whether you
should win or lose and then what
actually happened in the game
and he is just an absurd outlier like no
one's even close like a way up into the
right like i know i've seen on when
reviewing your podcast i see i saw that
you had guests who are soccer fanatics
so like lionel messi is a similar
outlier like you look at him compared to
anyone else and like goals and passive
it's just like virtuosity
and how he does it is just inspiring
like he has the standard of excellence
which is just unflinching like everyone
must be at the peak of their game all of
the time and he tolerates nothing except
for excellence
um
and then he's also super warm like he
adheres to the teddy roosevelt quote or
like
recorded by zig ziglar if people don't
care what you know until they know you
care like he really cares about his team
so he's able to be a hard ass because
people know it comes from a good place
and then like at some point it's a you
know virtuous feedback leap because they
just keep winning even when they don't
have like amazing talent like sure
they've had tim duncan they had why
leonard and whatever but they've also
had plenty of teams that like toe to toe
with the other team there's a talent gap
and they won
because of and also the last part is
relevant here the system so with a
franchise you buy a system he has a
system that just works so
and things like that like in business a
dan or her is an inspiring example like
the danaher business system and the best
franchises have really thoughtful
systems and that's what you're buying
that wasn't a deliberate tie back to
franchising it just sort of came
i i love it i love it and last question
what are a few words that would use to
describe yourself two to three words if
i were to think okay who's rob
huntington
what words come to mind
um
i think
a word is persistent
uh okay
so
uh an example of that is in college well
in college
in high school i wanted to get into
dartmouth college so i worked really
hard to get into dartmouth college and
did
um
because it had a work hard play hard
mentality and that struck me as [__]
um
uh i got there and i wanted to have fun
that was what i optimized for so i
persisted in having fun um i love it
then i wanted to work as a management
consultant and you know bcg bane
mckenzie and um they looked at my gpa
and said yeah i know um maybe in the
future i was like well fair okay so then
i worked over the the next bunch of
years on a series of things and
reapplied and you know seven years later
after getting a no was able to get in uh
which
was awesome like it was it was brutal
but super valuable training and i'm
grateful for it um i love this that's
what i got for you
and i'll take one more word
one more word um
a thing that my wife told me is kind of
defining of me is
wanting to get better at stuff like i'm
really driven by like
whatever it is like i think virtuosity
is an ideal one to itself that's really
beautiful so like
it definitely comes across in this talk
100 rob
cool so like for sales when i started
selling at my family you'd sell a
tutoring program that was okay
but i thought the beautiful thing was
like the deliberate practice of how to
get better and better and better over
time um same thing with being a ceo like
i'm a brand new ceo or six months into
the job
and i'm sure i like for a new ceo i'm
probably doing fine but relative to like
a seasoned ceo i'm probably pretty awful
but i'm confident that over time i can
you know work hard and get good at it so
i like getting better at stuff i find
that just fun unto itself
and i think that ties back to
persistence and and rob thank you very
very much for your time i really
appreciate it and and i and i just love
the conversation and so thank you for
your time and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you michael it's great
chatting with you take care
take care
you